les files d'attentes devant les
quincailleries grandes surfaces ne
laisse planer aucun doute
les rénovations ont la cote un teint de
confinement comme on voit la demi-heure
d'attenté pour entrer dans le kanak
c'est sûr qu'on s'occupe comme on peut
hein on apprend à devenir manuelles
comme on dit j'ai rénové mon troisième
étage je rénove ma cuisine avec ikea je
change ma piscine parce que c'était
croiser estivale ce secteur du commerce
au détail arrive à bien s'en sortir
secteur quelques ellipses imsand
aujourd'hui on parle d'augmentation ont
peut-être encore des 50% des ventes
présentement par rapport à la période de
cinq ans au lycée quand l'essentiel les
quincailleries n'ont pas eu à fermer
leurs portes
elles sont devenues un rempart contre
l'ennui et ça s'observe sur leur chiffre
d'affaires
c'est pour le doubs mais c'est bien ça
c'est considérable les personnes à se
retrouver chez elle retrouver à vouloir
faire des projets
donc nous on était là pour le sport
mental peut-être monde puis les projets
de la maison dans ce centre de
rénovation on a rapidement senti le
besoin des clients pour un changement de
décor et jean baucou redécoré le courant
du mois d'avril de rester chez soi 24
heures sur 24 on regarde les affaires
des choses qui nous tanne pour les
remarque pas quand on n'est pas à la
maison
le mec là tout le temps on eu beaucoup
de gens qui sont dit que les travaux
n'étaient pas prévues qui ont 18 ans kai
eide
on rénove malgré les apparences il n'ya
pas nécessairement davantage de clients
mais ceux qui se rendent en magasin
dépensent plus le phénomène qui se passe
c'est que les jeunes homologues magazine
pour le pré acheté fait donc la
clientèle qui vont en magasins achètent
et achètent davantage oncle
la valeur moyenne des achats est plus
grave et c'est souvent le budget des
vacances qui est consacré aux
rénovations le monde sont chez eux donc
le budget vacances devient budget mains
sont déjà une certaine résilience par
rapport à nos projets de vacances qui
avait prévu cet été on sent qu'on voit
on voit et on a tous à la maison ou très
près de la maison là la machine est
partie
ici on croit que cette tendance va
rester pense que ça va se traduire le
même pour les prochaines saisons mais ce
n'est pas gagné d'avancé car l'avion
disponibles ensemble il est encore trop
tôt pour voir comme
la crise transformera les habitudes de
consommation à plus long terme ici
valérie gamache radio canada québec